ladies and gentlemen i'm a little pissed
off today
because i keep getting the same comment
over and over you guys think you're so
smart
telling me hey hey steven uh your your
your door's backwards
it looks like you're standing outside of
your office not inside of your office
hey you guys haven't even seen the 10
million dollar studio yet
i mean you guys have to listen up every
single episode you can hear the fake
sound here i'll turn up i'll turn up the
volume
you hear that that's the sound of
construction
for the 10 million studio going on so
yeah actually i've been just sitting
outside my office this entire time
people pass by all the time you wonder
why i have so many jump cuts
it's because people start walking by so
next time before you guys
give me lip let me do the work so all
part of the plan we're going to show you
the 10 million dollar studio
very shortly in fact i'm going to give
you a sneak preview
at the end of this video but before any
of that happens sorry we got to take
these off
i want to tell you guys a story about
diabetes island
this is brought to you by our good
friends at clickbank let's watch
tell your children and husband you love
them and say goodbye to the doctor
you will be in a diabetic coma very soon
and i don't know what will happen
next terrified and barely conscious my
wife looked over at our two kids
standing outside
as he showed us the test results my
normal blood sugar reading was 120.
hers was 488 what watch them should
watch the show
i'm not ready to comment on it yet hold
on my badass wife the boss of our family
a proud lady who would shut up anyone
brave enough to give her lip
trembling cold and white as a sheet 30
short minutes
that was all he was giving my dear wife
kathy before she would fall into
unconsciousness
as she lay in the cold steel hospital
bed contemplating the most depressing
future she could imagine
i felt ashamed anger at god for
inflicting this pain and misery on such
a beautiful caring loving woman
hang on what is don't bring god into
this your wife's in a diabetic coma
god didn't put the ho hos in her hand i
mean what do you want me to tell you
so back up sorry he pissed me off you
see despite what you've been told
your uncontrolled blood sugar and
increasing belly fat has nothing to do
with
how many sugars or carbohydrates you eat
how much exercise you do
what medications you take or even
genetics or the aging process
this man's out here overturning
everything we know about diabetes
not due to food not due to exercise not
even due to aging or genetics what
what could it be but it is instead all
down to a little known but highly
dangerous toxin
found on every corner of earth oh of
course it's the little note sacred how
could i have not guessed
it's never diet and exercise that's
never the answer to any health problems
on clickbank what was i thinking didn't
i know it's the little known secret
but what is that secret but there is an
answer by using
a simple 60-second habit twice a day
known only to the inhabitants
of a small barely populated aegean
island
that's right ladies and gentlemen this
is where we come
to diabetes island diabetes island is a
special place
in the hearts of this man but first of
all who is this man
hello my name is eric woodfield i'm an
iron worker
my wife kathy and i live in oregon new
york and i'm 53 years old he's assaulted
the earth man
a blue color man he's the kind of man
that wouldn't lie to you
i've been a hard working guy all my life
scaling skyscrapers
and even done some ship fitting in my
day ship
fitting he's a ship fitting man believe
it or not i was even part of the cleanup
crew sent to the ground zero
after 9 11. oh come on
isn't it enough to lie to everyone do
you have to bring 911 into
it i probably could have guessed that
honestly if you'd given me some options
he's a ship fitting man of course he he
was on the cleanup crew of 911. in fact
he was also part of the seal team six
raid on osama bin laden that's the kind
of man this man is
words are just so inadequate to try and
share with you what i saw and felt
during those long awful days
you really understand what it means to
come under attack and do you know
something
that's happening to our bodies each and
every day
did this man just try to compare
diabetes to a terrorist attack
he's like i know what it's like to be
under attack from plane hijacking
terrorists
you know what else is a plane to
hijacking terrorists your blood cells
driving it right into the twin towers of
your aorta
fortunately for you a bizarre chain of
events handed me the weapon i needed to
defeat this invisible diabetes
causing toxins for good and save my
wife's life dude if this were actually a
true story which
obviously i'm sure you guys know by now
it's not this would be the greatest
movie ever told
they'd make a hollywood movie every year
from this and then remake that movie
every single year this would be the
greatest story of all time if this were
true
but you know what is true this guy
hates the belly fat that this diabetes
caused he found it
disgusting he keeps bringing it up in
the story she piled on more and more
weight
she went from the energetic motivator to
sluggish and overweight
in the space of just four years kathy's
weight had ballooned from a relatively
healthy 160 pounds to a massive 216.
yeah you can't talk about your wife that
way don't use the word
massive as an adjective by the way let's
have a look at those little uh before
and after
shall we going from this to a slim and
sexy 160 pounds
because all of a sudden when the magic
diet is tried
we get a before and after that seem a
little sus
computer enhanced something about those
faces
seems suspicious first of all nothing in
her face changed kathy has the
remarkable ability to maintain the exact
same face shape even after going from a
massive
216 pounds to a relatively healthy 160
pounds so of course you know me had to
look into it
and what do you know somebody else
actually did the work for me contra
health scam
shout out they discovered that this lady
had been photoshopped from
another weight loss journey this is the
real lady her name is
kristen w and she won a little prize for
losing the most weight and they took
this poor lady and they photoshopped her
and photoshopped a new face on her to
give her the face of a 911 man's wife
right but let's suspend our disbelief
and continue with this
journey of eric whitfield he's on a
quest to discover the true cause the
hidden secret
they don't want you to know about i left
online post on forums and
message boards he's all on like 4chan or
8chan asking q
what the secret to diabetes is i got a
reply from a man we will call
kevin over a call he revealed to me the
three closely guarded and biggest lies
of the diabetic industry and this is the
big diabetes lie number one
lowering blood sugar will reverse
diabetes next kevin revealed big
diabetes lie number two
this one shocked me exercise helps
reverse diabetes like
this guy's just lying to you i mean i
hope everyone knows that and giving out
harmful information exercise actually
does help also he can sell you a stupid
product if medications exercise and carb
restrictions had done nothing
and would never do anything to help
cathy's diabetes then what could help
sadly kevin didn't have the answer
and that's when he discovered diabetes
island and i was close to giving up
and that's when i discovered something
that chilled me to the bone oh sorry we
gotta get into the
super dramatic story before we get into
that hold on one second
i'm embarrassed to share this with you
but i feel i have to
using kathy's laptop one night i
stumbled onto some of her google
searches
best way to kill yourself said one query
hey
lady just cut back on the twinkies a
little bit you don't have to go that way
we all eat a few too many quarter
pounders from time to time
just chill out eat a salad it's not
gonna kill you
i had no idea kathy was feeling that low
i was desperate to help her but
i didn't know how but that very night i
received a phone call that would change
everything
that call came from my boss i had gotten
an offer earlier that week for a big
project over in greece right after
after my long flight i'm introduced to
the team of guys i was supervising
a group of 19 men from all over greece
among those
was alexander dukkha and seven other
guys who came to work on the project
from their home
on a tiny greek island called haukai
welcome
we finally come full circle jeez these
things are so long as the weeks went on
i came to realize these eight guys who
were all in their mid 50s
didn't have diabetes or even a single
symptom of it they were slim
healthy and full of energy yeah maybe
it's because they're outside working
back home i didn't know of one person
over 50 who didn't have diabetes let
alone
eight of them so that night i took alex
to one side and told him
all about my wife's conditions alex
smiled petted me on the shoulder and
told me to wait where i was
a few minutes later he returned with a
notepad and a pencil
and began to scribble down what looked
like a recipe what's this i asked
looking down the list the secret you've
been searching for he said with a glint
in his eye
you see eric i'm a wizard our health is
all
down to the food we eat he continued
mysteriously
it's not that mysterious but a second
ago you were saying diet doesn't have
anything to do with diabetes which is it
eric come on come on now
eat these foods and your wife will
recover with that
alex stood up gave me a knowing smile
and got back to work
only then did i remember that alex and
his friends always made those homemade
dressings with their lunch and dinner
sometimes even as a snack that's right
the secrets dressings
they're going to teach you how to make
for a small fee but look if you think
that's already gone to a conspiracy
level just wait
now stay with me here because this is
where it gets very interesting
particulate matter also known as pm 2.5
is a complex mixture of extremely small
particles and liquid droplets
they are emitted by fuel burning and
various industrial sources
but then get into the air and are
inhaled it's pretty scary right
you see this is the real cause of your
diabetes we know it's not because of
your diet or how much exercise you do
your health has been deteriorating
because of the invisible
pm 2.5 which has been seeping into your
bloodstream
for decades get your tinfoil hats on
boys because alice ain't seen nothing
yet
remember this graph we see diabetes
started around the 1940s
now look at this graph of pm 2.5 levels
over time
look familiar notice the rapid incline
at 1940 matches exactly when diabetes
spiraled out of control
oh come on eric no don't do that to us
don't give us the correlation equals
causation argument please
you guys ever seen the cheese conspiracy
before hey check this out
cheese consumption is apparently
correlated with people who died by
becoming tangled in their bed sheets
coincidence is it a coincidence that
when people ate more cheese they get
strangled in their bed sheets
i think not yeah it really was making
sense now and guess what
while the level of pollution in greece
was one of the highest in the world
far higher than the us i found out that
they actually had one of the lowest
levels of diabetes
hey boss we found out that our
hypothesis is severely undercut by the
fact that greece has
way higher pollution levels than
anywhere else what should we say
oh oh it just must be the the dressings
that are so powerful
it must be because of these traditional
dressings and the ingredients that make
them up
but the actual crazy thing is these guys
uh conveniently failed to mention
that pm 2.5 emissions they cut the graph
off at 2006
conveniently because they've actually
been falling in recent years
so their little theory doesn't line up
when diabetes
goes up and pm25 goes down they've
literally cut off the graph
right when it disproves their theory
completely because instead of actually
telling the truth
they want to spin up a crazy conspiracy
theory to endanger you
so they can make money brought to you by
the guy who's stealing valor from first
responders at 911
anyways i think that's a happy way to
wrap it up uh needless to say
don't ever follow these idiots advice or
really anything you see on clickbank
that's all for now i think uh you guys
have really earned this sneak peek that
i'm about to show you the 10 million
studio please enjoy thanks for watching
and as always
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe
thank you
you